[Música]
ora bulls pessoal do vídeo é mais um
vídeo e hoje vou ensinar como fazer
campos e do leônidas que vocês tanto
pedira a primeira coisa que vocês vão
ter que fazer é carregar no primeiro
link da inscrição e imprimir essas
folhas que vocês estão vendo aqui agora
e além destas vão vir mais duas que não
estão visíveis agora que é só juntar uma
outra é pronto vão juntar aqui com fita
crepe primeiro com pedaços pequenos
depois contar seus cremes não é que
fique como se fosse uma folha pronto só
feito isso vão individualizar aquela
parte que vocês virem desenhar aqui
agora é só colar as folhas em cima de
pedaços de papelão convém que o plano
não seja muito grosso ela não vai ser
difícil depois de moldar um ok e pronto
estas duas folhas que vocês estão vendo
aqui agora são os que não viram alvo
caminho que vão servir para fazer a
partir de cristo do campus e agora vamos
recordar a queda para o concelho que
vocês usem um stiletto é mais fácil de
usar uma tesoura e claro se vocês forem
menores peçam ajuda o do toque
no final é só tirar a parte do papel
contendo as peças todas as 3 500
espécies mais pequenas e podem deixar
com o papel para não correr o risco de
estragar o que vocês vão ver isso mais
para frente
agora é só colar usando aqui cola quente
vocês podem usar outra cola mas vai ser
mais complicado uma vez que demoram
muito tempo as caras é só colar bastante
fácil e agora vamos juntar as duas
partes usando aqui dos pedacinhos de
papelão vai impor bastante cola uma vez
que a conexão é pequeno ok
olha só finalizar destilada e já está à
cabeça
agora vamos fazer essas péssimas aqui
para dar um encaixe final na parte de
cima do que você faz parte que eu não
tirei folha uma vez que são muito
pequenas e frágeis como vocês viram
agora é só por aqui é cristã espaço no
colo mg na extremidade
agora só porque o lateral me deixar um
crescimento entre as lâminas por esta
faixa em cima cai tem que ter essa
intenção na altura que forem fazer agora
é só colar colou primeiro na parte da
frente
deixam-se taepodong cola por mais
incrível faixa até o final
podem ir ajustando aqui a parte interna
já o fundo da crista uma vez tem um
orifício por dentro
no final é só colar esta parte
agora musculares espécie de triângulo na
parte frontal para ajudarmos depois
conseguir pôr é proteção facial do
campus e protesta par também não terei a
parte do papel é também muito frágil com
vocês viram agora é junta estas duas
partes usando fita crepe sistema junção
temporária depois de decolar o que eu
passei tudo podem tirar e substituir por
colo
agora vamos colar a atenção como eu vou
colar primário por nicola num deste lado
do tango deixam de sacar
depois é só colar do outro lado
feito isto o resto vai ser fácil vai
normal mês
vocês podem ver agora é só colar um lado
e depois do outro
desta vez sobrou um crina parte de trás
do capacete quando já vamos ver aqui é
pra você lembrar também o vosso caso
vocês podem encurtar o chefe depois para
juntar estas duas partes podem usar um
pedacinho de papel é ecoar ali por
dentro ou então pode usar só cola
[Música]
agora para finalizar é só colar esta
parte aqui para que o muro fosse uma vez
que é muito fina nesta quarta
até podem por outro lado também se
quiser
pronto já está e agora é vão juntar com
o ipva com água da coca-cola no estado a
água e depois comprou sindjornal é só
especulando no campus e desta maneira
bastante simples
só quero deixar claro que não como uma
cola que seca muito rápido e pronto só
chegamos ao fim
eu vou deixar aqui dois links deste lado
é pronto o primeiro nunca do candal que
fez o que eu passei do canal do dali em
um canal utilizado na questão de
capacetes proteções tudo em papelão tam
passem por lá que eu acho que valeu
muito a pena ver se vocês gostaram desse
projeto pronto como eu não vou pintar
uma vez que estou aqui em inglaterra e
está aí algum dinheiro para conseguir
realizar isto tutorial é pronto e não
vou pintar vou deixar e talvez por um
outro vídeo
mas se vocês quiserem pintar e quiserem
tudo teve algumas dicas a uma ideia é
gay no segundo link vão ser direcionados
para um vídeo da wii
o que eu sinto capaz e tu leônidas de ok
e pronto achei o joinha o favorito
inscreva os canais se não forem as
críticas ajuda bastante a divulgação é e
avaliação do nosso trabalho muito
obrigado e até a próxima